you know it's a deal we don't say
goodbye Andy Mack you and your friends
are seriously friendship goals we really
feel like we have gotten to know you
Cyrus and Buffy throughout the show and
we love knowing that it's not all fake
we love seeing all your real life photos
and videos on social media while we're
sad to see the show end we hope you guys
will stay friends forever I love you
guys Andy Mack ends forever in just a
few weeks in honor of this awesome show
we picked out the best behind-the-scenes
moments keep watching to see a huge cast
party and Peyton Lee's tribute to her
co-stars Sophia's Got News we absolutely
love this boomerang video of Sophia
Wiley aka
Buffy she is totally goofing it up on
set this video clip was posted by the
official Andy Mac Instagram account On
January 7 2019
it was Sophia's birthday this is such a
cute video we just know that sophia has
to be a ton of fun on set can you
imagine how much fun being a part of the
antimacassar been we can't wait to see
what great things Sophia does next just
be cool don't be all like uncool
Bowie's majestic hair Andy's real dad is
the young handsome Bowie he is played by
Trent Garrick and there is no doubt that
Trent has some amazing hair we snagged
this photo off of Joshua Russia's
Instagram account
on March 7th 2019 he posted this photo
of himself and Trent it's so cute
because friends has Josh on his back but
the funniest part is the caption Josh
said Trent's hair looks majestic here
he's totally right the cool cast part of
being a Disney Channel star is making
appearances at lots of public events on
October 30th 2018 the cast appeared at
an actress fund event Payton Sofia Josh
and Asher took an awesome photo Payton
posted this pic to her Instagram account
we just love how cool they look with
this hilarious pose Payton and the boys
look ready to drop the next hottest
album but Sofia just looks totally
unamused they must have so much fun
whenever they are together
friendship goals it must be really hard
for the cast to say goodbye to each
other they've spent three years becoming
awesome friends and they've been through
a lot too
and two characters that have grown a lot
are Andy and Jonah
Asher angel who plays Jonah posted this
cute photo back in April of 2019 he
posted a bunch of photos as a tribute to
his time on Andy Mac but this sweet shot
of him and Peyton got us right in the
fields I wonder what would have happened
if we met when we were older like mother
like daughter Beck's had a lot to learn
about me and a mom on the show but the
actress who plays her is a really great
role model for her younger stars you can
really tell that Lillian Boden cares a
lot about Payton leaned back in May of
2019 she posted this sweet video of the
two of them filming for Andy Mac had
already wrapped but Lillian said the
universe couldn't keep them apart they
were together in Toronto for an event
isn't this photo the cutest
it's so rare when your co-workers also
feel like your family members extreme
kayaking a bunch of the antimatter casts
got to go on a Disney cruise together
they are so lucky we love seeing the
photos from their adventures but this
video posted by the Andy Mac Instagram
account cracked us up Peyton and Joshua
went kayaking on their cruise and
apparently it was harder than it looked
Peyton didn't move much and at one point
we hear Josh scream then he runs into
her kayak while yelling it was so
hilarious good times on set we love when
we get a chance to see the set of our
favorite shows thankfully Sophia Wylie
shared several behind-the-scenes photos
while filming season three we loved this
picture of our favorite characters with
amber amber is played by Emily Skinner
her character has caused a lot of drama
on the show but this photo shows that
emily is not like that in real life at
all this is outside of the set for the
spoon dinner look how happy they are to
be filming goofing off sometimes the
cast of Andy Mack looks totally serious
at events but most of the time they are
totally goofing off
Peyton Lee shared this photo on June
21st 2019 the four main characters were
at Radio Disney and they are all making
hilarious faces it's kind of amazing
that they get anything serious done it
since they're always having such a blast
we love photos like this because it may
the stars seem so real to us we bet you
have plenty of pics like this with your
friends
Josh's rollercoaster ride one of the
perks of working for Disney Channel is
getting to visit Disney World the cast
got to visit the Orlando theme park in
January 2019 and Josh Rush filmed
himself riding on Expedition Everest
this scary roller coaster is an animal
kingdom and Josh looks so terrified
while he's riding it but he survived the
official Andy Mac Instagram page posted
this and we're glad they did do you
think it looks like fun or would you
totally pass on this ride
party time Andy Mack has been a super
important part of the cast live and back
in December of 2018 Payton Lee posted an
awesome tribute he said that the show
made her dreams come true she wrote that
she has so many amazing memories from
her time on set and she posted this
awesome video of the cast and crew party
they are dancing and just having an
awesome time together
it looks like an epic night what will
you miss about Andy Mack tell us in the
comment section thanks for watching like
this video and subscribe to the things
for more great contents we'll see you
next time
[Music]